you know this is the only franchise
where you go on Twitter and they say if
such-and-such happens I am so out thank
you I can't take credit for it my wife
and my daughter say you're wearing this
and it's great it's taken the way that I
don't have to make those choices myself
anymore just surround yourself with good
women you know that you got strong women
exactly Hyatt was one of seven children
and it was boy girl girl need girl girl
boy so I had like I was wedged in
between four really strong women you
could never make a relationship mistake
because you have all the sisters to tell
you the starwars divisive Ness has
switched over this morning to the Han
Solo movie because the trailer came out
this morning yeah have you seen it what
were your thoughts
there's divisive miss can you believe it
you know this is the only franchise
where you go on Twitter and they say if
such-and-such happens I am so out so now
they're speculating about things they
don't want to see it surprises me but
look you can't please everybody you just
have to try and make the best story you
can I was sort of taken aback by it but
who knows not everybody likes broccoli
some people like carrots or Brussels
sprouts better so you know that's just
the way life is
would you have advice for this Alden
Ehrenreich who's stepping into these
that he can't win well of course I mean
anybody they for the young anything like
when they did the young Indian oh not
the prequel to Butch Cassidy and the
Sundance Kid and Tom Berenger and
William count were great but they say oh
well he's not like Robert Redford he's
not like Paul Newman that's already hard
but the trailer looks fantastic I don't
know anybody's complaining about trailer
makes you want to see the movie and I'm
dying to see it so it worked so you're
in my final question before I let you go
Carrie Fisher won the posthumous Grammy
what was your reaction when you saw that
was elated but of course you know she
was nominated for an Emmy is she she
should be here gosh darn it you know I
mean that she just made everything more
fun if she were here tonight she'd be
behind you giving me the middle finger
because that was just her so I miss her
everyday and I you know I'm just glad
that people to keep her alive in their
hearts hey no one's ever really gone
that's right wow I can quote that
[Music]